it's time to bet that money sometimes
when I use this voice Josh smiles and I
know it's gonna be okay
Chris Sims is coming in today in second
place and the sims Aleph go betting show
following four-time champion Adam Lefko
the question is will they bet on the
same teams or could they be a playoff
push find out next one Sims in left go
the betting show why Chris why are you
wearing that Jersey the team lost
they're not good what am I wearing Chris
a Saints jersey number 92 Davenport what
am I wearing 92 Davin I'm wearing a
Reggie White Mitchell and Ness sweater
week too late bro it's a really bad
karma bad juju
we going to the game you sitting at home
with popcorn filling I love popcorn I'm
wearing this to show everybody that just
because your team loses don't pack it in
don't act distraught you've still got a
ride-or-die right and I rather die with
this team yep so uh you know who I'm
picking all right so Josh how we doing
this today perfect for most if you'd
like to come to Atlanta and you'd like
to be there for our show
email Sims a love Co at gmail.com we are
nearly filling up it's going to be crazy
and it's gonna be awesome I got a couple
more emails today of people who are
ready to back you any potential left go
vs Saints fans brawl we've got some
Panthers fans coming and some Falcons
fans coming back so just you know you've
got the NFC South with you that is the
good thing is I feel like there's a lot
of peers fans don't miss out on your
chance to take on the zone do it
Buccaneers side with me and go against
left go let's go Saints and Buxton will
gang up a let go okay come back up again
maybe our Wednesday podcast will just be
a straight roast roast we'll just yeah
just everybody can get in a lie but
here's the deal that's only if the
Saints make it now let's go to the show
all right we're in the same boat now
Saints fans coming out of the divisional
round Sims you went two and two last
weekend you lost on the Colts and the
Cowboys you are
the Patriots and the Eagles so what does
that mean he made you made $0 but you
also lost zero so glass-half-full
welcome to where I was between weeks 10
and 1 in the playoffs and I can't
[ __ ] win money and you're 6 and 2 but
that's ok
hey by this week oh yeah Josh mess it up
you're right no way am i normal just
straight-up pick still Ivan 3 hold on
What did he say he was not possible for
someone to go 7 1 the playoffs yeah
you've done it left go oh wait I would
just like to say my spreadsheets are
correct yeah okay sorry I was looking
right in a row yeah hold that up to the
camera this is not a joke okay
very well done left go last week you
went three and one bringing you to seven
and one in the playoffs don't worry
the Colts you were right on the Rams
Patriots and Eagles so heading into
championship weekend Sims you are at
2,170 bleacher bucks a great year left
go you were at three thousand three
hundred and forty bleacher bucks that's
a greater year and I've added another
formula here on the right side actually
you don't have this on your spreadsheets
but I have it now calculating and
subtracting the difference so I don't
have to do the math in my head
left go you are up 1170 Bleacher bucks
heading into championship all right so
you can still catch me what do you mean
like isn't he oh you're saying that's
what the dinner bag sorry correct got
you got you
so today you want to explain how we're
doing this today no you go right so left
go texted us said what was at midnight
last night and said I think we should
bet $1600 total on championship weekends
there was a notion that we were gonna do
$400 a game right but the only reason we
did $400 a game for a wild card
divisional was there were four games
thus equalling 1600 right I believe that
in this race two are two possibly my
fifth and your first right that the
playoffs should be worth more than the
rest of the games because these are the
teams we've watched all year long right
it means more to them it should mean
more to us right and I also think it's
gonna be crazy going down the stretch
if you go up 1600 I go down and now
suddenly for the $1600 winner-take-all
Super Bowl sure it flips again I know
I'm willing to risk my lead
because if there
excellent strategy I mean yes thank you
for giving me a chance I guess what
you're saying but I almost would have
rather done that 400 per game just uh we
could really gone like if you've been
tough it would have been tough but this
is cool I'm down with that is it tougher
yeah yeah well it's easier to make a
comeback is what I'm saying if now yes
we're also not a legally sanctioned
sports book so we can really do it every
weekend yes make it more exciting you
know what this room is
we're gonna be opposites anyways it
doesn't you know what I'm thinking what
are you thinking I'm realizing that in
Game of Thrones
which you don't watch you know when that
dude thought he had killed the mountain
yeah he's like you dark day you come
until my village and you know come my
people and then the mountain cut and
crushed his head I think that's what I
just did The Sims
I think he's gonna grab my leg put me on
the ground squash my head and then I was
amazing yep it was an amazing part of
that show was it actually was did you
see it yeah mountains crushing people
it's amazing
well the mountain is just a nickname for
a human oh very large human who I think
he wasn't he did he do the combine that
guy had an NFL oh it's that guy yes yeah
okay all right my name is the mountain
on the shell show yeah it's kind of fun
he's like a world-famous bodybuilder
right he's known as the mountain he's
now a zombie mountain he's a zombie but
he's even sorry someone's someone's like
pumped something into his veins that's
brought him back is that show still
going on it's the last season I hope
they keep making them is one one zombies
alive one one is in the ground he's in
the ground no he's not a white Walker
ooh he might feel like I feel like one
one came back as a white Walker right so
that just means he's soul Simpson ever
dies crossed over the dark side
basically okay now he's gonna try and
take off he was good originally really
was if this was like the wrong guy tried
to kill phil simms and many it's Reggie
why yes if I was doing content I would
have Sims only watch the finale of Game
of Thrones and try to sum up what the
entire show was based off of only the
finale
what about it's like if I watch Survivor
I was like she never had a chance for
the beginning we gotta get dad to tell
the story about Jerome Brown God rest
his soul
about the day he found out they were
going to draft Jerome Brown no I think
you've told me in the weight room that
Bill Parcells yeah yeah and Bill
Parcells is like they got
Brown he's like no he's Detroit had to
pick before them and he was like ah Sims
Detroit's gonna [ __ ] this draft up
they're gonna take blah blah blah that
means the Eagles are gonna get Jerome
Brown and like you know I you know of
course the deagles defense was already
amazing they didn't need him yeah yeah
alright alright sorry I'm ready gamble
the time before free agency yeah can you
imagine well that was the last era of
great teams right because there was no
salary cap and that's the reason like no
salary cap and players never left no and
I mean the 49ers they out paid everybody
that's why they were so dominant like
nobody competed like DeBartolo was not
afraid to spend money to make money I
guess basically it was like baseball
yeah it was it becomes a coastal sport
then though again it's the New York's
and the Boston's and the LA's that make
more and I think I'm torn because the
NFL's great because any team can make a
run and a team like the Rams can go
worse to first and it seemed like the
Eagles could have done that the year
before true but then there's also
baseball when I turn it on and it's
Yankees Red Sox yeah and I don't need to
know a single player but I know it's for
everything yeah and it feels great and I
look back in those Cowboys in the 90s
and the the 49ers in the 80s it's
special no yeah to your point I mean
actually I never even thought of it this
way but if you go from 1980 all the way
till let's say 1995 right it was nothing
but what you're saying it was Raiders
Niners ok Raiders are the only AFC team
at one time some Giants Redskins yeah ok
Dallas and then the Bears which is a big
city team right which makes sense I mean
that was all major sell is it yeah so
you're right it's definitely an issue
and the MBA it's getting interesting now
because you know who Minnesota gets this
guy for three years right now but he's
gonna leave now New Orleans I know is
gonna leave Indiana and then where do
they go yeah but that's why I like Paul
George and Oklahoma City's wild yeah it
is it is cool that he kind of stayed
there yeah and then you become excited
to get back into basketball a little
here soon yes James Harden's out there
dropping 58 ok this is how this is gonna
go today so I'm gonna give the matchup I
will give the weather I will give the
line Oh we'll go over to you Chris for
your breakdown and pick we will go over
to Adam for his breakdown and pick then
we'll do a little left go inventory
where he'll ask you a bunch of questions
ok we're gonna do about 30 minutes on
each game and then we'll move on cool so
first game Sunday afternoon 3:05 the Los
Angeles Rams on the road visiting the
New Orleans Saints last time these two
teams played at the Superdome earlier
this year
45:35 Saints win weather in New Orleans
on Sunday in case anyone's curious 49
degrees is the high mostly sunny a
little bit of wind spread in this game
Chris New Orleans - three and a half ok
I'm like I just got so many I got too
many people like just text them and I
just can't just hit you up now nobody
I'm looking they own text now but I just
gotta be be texting he's like it's just
that time of the year I don't know he's
got about 85 texts to his wife with no
it's breaking down this game and I
suggest that again that he opened the
Notes app maybe instead of texting I
think we'll get there eventually all
right here we go
Saints Rams all right let's just do
let's go a little backtrack and just
talk about the first matchup right first
matchup very interesting in a whole lot
of ways you know I think the first thing
I would say is both defenses at that
time still had not found themselves all
the way like where I just say there was
unsound things they did in the secondary
and as defenses altogether I would say
that both defenses at that time were
just a hair too aggressive and we're
talking the week 9 matchup that the that
Josh just references they see what you
say the spread of this game is I have
not even looked at the right-half okay
so so from there what he has looked at
the spreads but he's made bets
I made my scores and I made my bets yep
okay Denton dear but either way mix it
up during the championship either way I
I think what's interesting is it's you
know first thing is the Rams are a
different team right now right you know
Dante Fowler just got there Marc Baron
just got back in the lineup
Aqib Talib was not there so from that
aspect of your a Rams fan you look at it
and go okay that's good to know you know
on the other side of the ball the Saints
on their defense in that first matchup
we're still living in this like oh we
think we could play a lot of man-to-man
and stop people that way and there was
just too many easy pull
altogether I think the thing that I
forgot about in the first matchup that
was interesting is just that the Rams
did run the ball on the Saints really
that's a moment he did but they got
behind and they really couldn't stay
with it right on the other side of
course the Saints ran the ball against
the Rams as well and that was when you
know the Rams were just all over the
place I mean there's a few snaps in the
game where the Rams are like talking to
me on the 70 yard bomb to Michael
Johnson of course Marcus Peters has
literally turned around talking to
somebody and they snapped the ball and
he tries to turn around and guard the
guide also say there were times where
Aaron Donald was behind Brees and there
was a run going the other way right like
it was it was back to the Aaron Donald
I'm gonna run up as hard as I can
leaving holes all over the without a
doubt it was the whole undisciplined
what I questioned really even last week
and that's why I did not expect the
Cowboys to get blown out the way they
did because I was just like man I don't
know I mean even though the Rams played
close to the vest and that last two
games of the regular season I just
thought it's the cowboys and they're
gonna take a chance at some point
they'll get cached so I guess where do I
want to go with this I think if I was
going to Matt talk about the Rams
offense versus the Saints defense just
to go to that matchup first of all
there's no Cooper Cup now for the Rams
on that side of the ball that's big
certainly the Saints are more of a
definitely a zone team that's what they
want to do and they're gonna match up in
just certain little situations and
man-to-man and do all of that now you
have to be careful about playing too
much man-to-man against the Rams because
with the speed sweeps and the run game
and everything they can test you that
way you know the other thing that the
RAM the Rams offense is very good at is
they are good at flooding zones in the
pass game in the drop back pass game and
when the Saints did play zones the Rams
did a pretty good job of finding you
know two three on twos or two on ones
and things like that but I don't think
my big point would be this for the
Saints defense don't be scared to play
man-to-man in this game
I mean Jared Goff is struggling a little
right now and he made some great throws
against man-to-man in that game but we
haven't seen him make those throws
consistently lately and I would say if
I'm the Saints like don't be scared to
do that make
but early on I would test it and go
let's see if he's on his game right
let's just see you know so you go from
there
okay so then you flip it over to the
other side and you know this is really
the Enigma I mean the the the Saints
offense you like that use your vested
horse coming out today yeah well the
Saints the Saints offense you know as
far as run games concern I guess where I
get scared a little bit for their run
game is that they've struggled with some
of the faster type of defensive lines
like the Cowboys and that way right
where they're actually been better
against the Eagles and the Ravens are a
little lumbering they're a little
lumbering is a big man right yeah right
Taryn Terrell yeah right Rams check big
man Wofford big band right so that's
where it just like just a little food
for thought as far as where that goes
you know the Rams defense you know
having to leave back I don't think the
Rams are gonna live in an man-to-man
but I do think a Talib matches up better
with a Michael Thomas than Marcus Peters
I mean again absolutely yeah again like
Marcus Peters covered Michael Thomas
pretty well but when it just came down
to oh I'm gonna come out of my break
like Michael Thomas just overpowered
Marcus Peters in times where he's there
in coverage and the rest let them play
and Michael Thomas just pushed him off
and caught the ball and then broke a
tackle or whatever it was like Peters
wasn't in bad position right and I think
we said that at the time so that's
really interesting I mean I think the
first thing we need to say about both of
these games these games are like
fascinating to me I have never gone in
the AFC Championship game going like I
don't feel comfortable it's like a coin
flip it's only 50 v yes there's there's
really it's like I could find ways and
every matchup to go oh well this team
has this and this team has that I just
want to make sure I'm looking at my text
here just to make sure I didn't but I do
think the fact that the Rams have
simplified on defense is going to be an
advantage for them just in the fact
where they're not gonna get caught with
their pants down so many times there was
just so many plays where the the Saints
motion to cross and they're all
communicating and trying to fix to the
coverage and they snap the ball and
they're really not in position to cover
the play right and you talked about how
the Rams defensive line was kind of all
all over the place and Dante Fowler just
got there and he only played it was
snaps right he played limited snaps in
the game in general as the game went on
they started to get pressure on Brees
but early on they didn't and I would say
for anybody out there one of the great
matchups of the game will be Andres Pete
who struggled last week against him and
Aaron Donald because they will not be
afraid to leave Pete on Donald's
one-on-one and say no you're a
first-round pick and we're gonna let you
take him man-to-man so that's going to
be really awesome - I don't feel overly
confident about either quarterback in
this matchup I kind of look at both
quarterbacks as going hey the two best
quarterbacks in the playoffs are in the
AFC side right now mahomes is one brady
is - all right
then hey some Hill and then three and
four would be the NFC matchup I'm just
talking about the style of the way these
two quarterbacks are playing right now
um let me just see if I'm missing
anything else I don't think I am from
that just as far as things that I want
to look up from that first matchup again
don't forget this aspect of the game - I
thought Sean McVeigh made a huge mistake
in the first game with the fake field
goal they got the fumble and just take
the field goal and go up 1714 instead
they went for the fake field goal didn't
get it it became 2114 then they drove
the ball down the field again and then
missed the field goal and became 2824
and then gone through the interception
and became 35 34 and that kind of took
the Rams out of their run game how we've
already mentioned the Rams defense is
improved the Saints defense is improved
the Rams run game is rolling right now
that's where I just look at it to be
interesting if the Rams of course in the
Saints is one of the best run defenses
football that's really to me are gonna
be a huge area of the game if the Rams
can run the ball on the Saints you know
then it's just gonna put them in a bind
of play-action pass and all of those
type of things and you know that's the
same for the other side but I do think
that the Rams secondary can match up
better with the Saints weapons than vice
versa okay I only trust Marcus lad
more on man-to-man coverage right he's
the only guy I really trust like on the
Saints Eli Apple he has his moments but
I certainly one wouldn't want him living
on an island too much throughout the
game against woods or Brandon cooks Sean
Lattimore Marsh on them as I say Marcus
yes so that that to me is fascinating as
well no Sheldon rankings on the inside
who had some moments in this game of
really being disruptive that hurts the
Saints to where I look at it and you
know it's just uh it's a it's an awesome
game where I look at it and go what
quarterback is gonna make the big throws
okay
and what's the more talented team and I
think like at the end of the day I came
to my determination that I'm betting
$800 in the Los Angeles Rams I'm
thinking the Rams to win this football
game
I think the Rams are gonna win this game
27 to 24 something along those lines
I just think the Rams are more talented
and I actually think they're playing
better football right now and I like
what they've done on defense and I just
think if Donald and Sue can stay you
like the Rams moneyline uh I guess yeah
I think the Rams are gonna win this game
gotcha they're gonna go in to New
Orleans and win I just feel like in a
one game in a one-game scenario McVeigh
Wade Phillips and just the absolute
freak show of the Los Angeles Rams is
gonna be ready to go I just think they
got more talent across the board in a
game that's very evenly matched and you
go either way I'm gonna go with the
superstar power of Gurley woods cooks
you know golf to leave Peters Fowler
Donald sue brokers I'm gonna Marcus
joiner I'm gonna go with them in this
one game scenario that their talent will
be able to just overcome the fact that
it's a very even matchup and yeah I
think it's like a 27 24 28 24 type
victory for the Rams I'm gonna give you
my first nugget yeah that applies to all
the games this week in both games yeah
Sims 2017 Patriots beat the Jaguars at
home Eagle
beat the Vikings at home yeah 2016
Falcons beat the Packers at home right
Patriots beat the Steelers at home right
2015 Broncos beat the Patriots at home
yeah Panthers beat the Cardinals at home
2014 Seahawks beat the Packers at home
Patriots beat the Colts at home 2013
Broncos beat the Patriots at home
Seahawks beat the 49ers at home yeah not
since 2012 has a visiting team won a
championship game and both well that's
just for everyone out there and with the
Niners over the Falcons in Atlanta Colin
Kaepernick incredible throw Ravens over
the Patriots Joe Flacco goes to the
Superbowl right
oh it's yeah yeah right the two thousand
twelve two thousand twelve thousand
twelve the Ravens played the 49ers the
fourteenth website okay those were the
championship oh yeah I got you got you
got you I'm thinking in the next other
championship game sorry my boss so I'm
just saying it's something that no one's
talking about I haven't heard it
anywhere yeah no team win a championship
game and in about five years right I
think that's crazy it is looking at the
injury reports yeah Saints lost Sheldon
Rankin's Andrus peat max Unger Rams ik
all limited on Wednesday Rams injury
report nobody right nobody I went back
and watch week 9 yeah first thing I
thought then Watson was incredible
mm-hmm like and he's not even playing an
hour but he had he had two or three
incredible catches I thought got well
you're both wearing the sweater shirt
combination which this looks very hot
well it's 20 degrees out that's true
golf the first thing I wrote down was
golf looks like he belongs in the dome
yeah like the way the ball was coming
out of his hands back then it was poppin
right I also go man Sean Payton what a
savage up 11 with eight minutes left in
the third calls a flea-flicker yeah gets
it yeah but like the amount of times I
went back and watched Sean Payton games
it's that time in the third quarter
where everyone kind of gets in their
ruts that's when he calls the Willie
Snead pass it actually calls the
flea-flicker but to be up 11 and do that
I just thought was wild yeah it looked
easier for the Saints than it
did the Rams write chimera is the wild
card in this game because he had success
forgot it was the Michael Thomas
cellphone game and then I said oh damn
these teams played in 2017 also in LA
yeah let me watch that game right Brees
was under pressure the entire game right
Alvin Kamara and girly
both had monster games but the Rams won
26 to 20 and was really 26 to 30 n--
they controlled that whole game it was
all Rams in that game good job by you
going back to watch that one but guess
what right they also played in 2016 yeah
Jeff Fisher right Jared golf's first
road game of his career right was in the
Superdome that's funny so Jared Goff
this is his third time playing in the
Superdome yeah but I couldn't believe
that his first his first NFL touchdown
pass was in the Superdome right he's
running down guess what he did in that
game what three touchdowns one
interception ball was flying out of his
hands my Jared golf in the dome yeah
it's a different guy yeah
Aaron Donald killed breeze forced a
fumble that was recovered in the way so
he was on the team too right it was one
of those hits where Drew Brees his head
is still but his back is back five yards
in that game up 42 to 21 up 21 points
yeah with ten minutes left in the game
Sean and Peyton calls a pass to Willy
Sneed who then throws it for a touchdown
so Sean Payton has now done this twice
right against the Rams in the Superdome
yeah third or fourth quarter having a
wide receiver throwing a pass for a
touchdown sure thing you don't think
he's gonna do that this weekend I mean
either one of these coaches I'd be
scared to death I'd be keeping me up at
night if I'm a head coach for either one
of these teams Jared Goff against the
Saints and I believe it's also Jared
golf against Dennis Allen over the last
three years I believe dennis has been
there the last time yes to yes three
games averaging 320 yards a game eight
touchdowns three interceptions
he's Owen too in New Orleans but that
was with Jeff Fisher and to watch that
defense get butchered was it didn't even
recognize that Ram
right one in Owen in LA but he's played
two games in New Orleans so here I have
a guy he's been there yeah his first
career touchdown was there right he put
up 35 points the next time yeah they
know what it's like to be down 21 I
don't think there's a fear factor for
this team I don't imagine that either
but those are great Nuggets Lovegood and
I also think that I just watched Sean
McVeigh yeah he put up points against
the Cowboys and I know Sean Payton
against the team is gonna be good but
this is all show Sean McVeigh having
faced a team twice and he's got to know
this team well too
yeah but I honest I genuinely believe
that Sean McVeigh and Sean Payton are a
wash I think Sean McVeigh has the
advantage in the first two quarters and
Sean Payton probably has the advantage
in the last two murders because he's
been in a championship game at home
before he knows what it takes he's a
little bit more risky he's and I shade
that way from a field goal kicker
standpoint I even went back and looked
oh what do you know Greg Zuerlein
drilled a 56 yarder in that game this
year
yeah and the Superdome so I have a
little bit more confidence in deeper
field goals with Zuerlein that I do with
will lot so we just saw miss a
50-something yarder against the Eagles
and then I said I wonder how Michael
Thomas has been at home against the Rams
25 targets 21 catches 319 yards three
touchdowns right Michael Thomas has had
success against this team yeah the only
home NFC championship game for the
Saints with Peyton and Brees over this
whole tenure was the Favre win over the
Vikings I went back and watched that
game yeah
holy [ __ ] the Vikings had four turnovers
I don't even know how they were still in
the game I mean Brett Favre should have
had that game won Brett Brees was not
really doing anything they were the
better team that the Vikings were the
better tenant but I watched that game
just to go let me see the Sean Payton
wrinkles right and I didn't see any yeah
so the only other non football thing
right factored into my equation and I
don't know why it matters to me but it
does drew Brees had his 40th birthday
party this week it was like on Monday he
was dancing his tail off huh I think it
was after the game on Sunday wasn't it
near Monday right and like any
traditional white guy he did the one
move during the year and people liked it
so what was the one move he pulled out
at his birthday that same one and then
he did the Det
it's just like this arm thing that's
like I don't I think it might be in New
Orleans dance yeah but then he did the
dadlab afterwards where he's like really
serious then he goes and like laughs
around but there was something about
watching drew brees and the whole Saints
team celebrating his birthday and I know
it's on a Monday I just thought in my
head
do you believe Drew Brees has gone out
on any Mondays this year and I'm not
saying that those two or three hours I'm
not saying he shouldn't have been
partying it's his 40th birthday I'm just
saying that the last few years the team
that has had the emotional win I feel
like has faltered the next week
Vikings lat last year on that big win
fell flat I just felt like there's been
some other wins where they felled flat
and the Chiefs the Chiefs and the
Patriots didn't really have emotional
wins yeah right the Saints did I did
yeah they were in deep crap so I think
the Saints are gonna be able to run
right I think that this is gonna be
Camaro doing what he wants to do I think
the the issue that I have in the Saints
is the lack of depth behind Michael
Thomas for wide receiving weapons
everything is a big deal it does because
I watched Ed Gein lose the ball in the
lights last week on a play that they
should have completed for like a 40 50
yard and the the Smith kid hasn't been
there as much right it's it's Alvin it's
Ingram and it's Thomas no doubt I don't
see anything else from the tight ends
recently and it's Taysom Hill it's taste
some Hill so he's definitely a weapon
chair drew Brees inability to go deep I
think it's gonna be a really big thing
mcveigh I think it's gonna stress out
the Saints and run on them right I of
the Rams winning 31 30 I'm putting $800
in the Rams to me yeah yeah for me it
was it was when it was four for Wade
Phillips I think to see Drew Brees as
arm limitations and I think that because
the Rams themselves are a special teams
trick play team yeah I don't think
they're ever going to do what Fletcher
Cox and the Eagles did which
let up I think that they I would hope
they would be ready for it at all times
yes and I think it is a little bit more
of the athletes I think losing Sheldon
Rankin's is enormous oh yeah and I think
that Aaron down on them will get
pressure with my fear is that I am
betting on Jared Goff over Drew Brees
because I think that's the beer if
they're both limited Drew Brees is the
one that should be able to get it done
yeah right because of the experience
sure he's being there before not being
overwhelmed by the moment yeah I agree
that's the number one fear for me too
but I mean again so evenly matched and I
think your logic is exactly like mine
you're just going with the team where I
go okay they're just a few more studs on
this team and this is a one game one
game must-win situation and the fact
that Jared Goff has played there twice
and the ball has popped out both times
yeah like I'm talking about his first
touchdown was like a deep corner where
he led the receiver to the post yeah but
it was like a line and then when I
rewatched that last game I haven't seen
Jared Goff look like that in week I
threw phenomenal throws so I think about
this guy in a situation where he should
be somewhat comfortable right uh yeah
and I thought the Rams D listen at the
end of the day - I thought the Rams
played better last week than the Saints
did I just liked after not only going
back to watch that you know week 9 game
but the film when I came away getting
done with the film yesterday of of the
Sunday games I remember just thinking
man the Saints I don't think there was
impressive to me as the Los Angeles Rams
and I can't believe I'm doing it cuz I
really thought going in going to the
week and the logic and I was I go it's
Saints at home why would I ever bet on
Jared Goff on the road in a playoff game
yeah and maybe one of the best
home-field advantage is in the sport
against maybe the second-best
quarterback coach combination of our
generation behind Brady and Belichick
it's Peyton and Brees yep and I'm
sitting here and I'm for me from a
betting standpoint I think that half a
point is huge yeah that three and a half
and not three right the fact that the
Saints can win by a field goal at the
end and I still win yeah
I liked it yeah but yeah it's it's scary
with Jared Goff but no it's alright I
you know I also have faced with like
just like I do with a Sean Payton when
those quarterbacks are struggling you
know these these coordinators are head
coaches find ways to still move the ball
and make them feel comfortable and still
make the offense go so that's where I
feel like they can overcome it and you
know yeah sure you know it's it's a
fascinating game I am so excited for
this weekend because I just think that
overall the matchups of these football
games are very very evenly matched to
where yeah you could come up with little
ifs or what's about each game yeah I
think the other thing too that just
they're just they're just head cam
Jordans a really good player there's
just no killers or huge different makers
important not yet not right now I mean
he did not pop to me I want to say
something about one guy that I've got
played really well against the Eagles
and I thought he's played really well
down the stretch - Mario Davis oh come
on
I just don't think we've talked about
him and I know we probably have no
Saints in free agency got him from the
New York Jets and he is providing the
thumper in the middle that the Saints
have been missing for the last few years
and he's an underrated athlete - you can
go side to side and the running backs
couldn't get away from him yeah I think
he is the difference maker for the
Saints defense that nobody talks about
right I think a lotta Moore and Eli
Apple or fine I think their safety play
is fine I think cam Jordan is special
but really Demario Davis is the one that
I think is really great for me that gave
me a lot of confidence in the Rams it
was looking at who was playing in the
secondary last time and realizing now
with Peters to leave John Johnson and
LaMarcus Joyner all four of them are
really great yes and I and they don't
other than Peters who is a little risky
they don't make a lot of boneheaded
decisions yeah where I could see Eli
Apple and I could see some other people
and that defense may be doing that yeah
right
it just comes down to we're betting on
the team that doesn't have the
experience and that's always scary it is
no question about it
you could anything we're missing on that
game I don't think so Torrey to do
you know I don't know if there's
anything else we're missing um you know
again just for people out there I think
one of the key matchups early on we'll
be able to just see is well Donald's
ensue hold there gaps like they did last
week against the Cowboys the same way
they did against the Saints my inventory
will be this yeah
if Sean Payton watched the Rams footage
right what do you think his attack is
gonna be if Sean Payton watched the ran
watch Rams Cowboys and he watches Rams
Saints yeah I mean he's never gonna
learn to formulate he's never gonna
leave the run game but like the Cowboys
running game yeah
what do you think he learned what not to
do from that oh well I think the first
thing is he is a he is a little bit more
I think of a versatile run game in
general than the Cowboys and I think you
could argue that their offensive line is
as good or better than the Cowboys and
their play actual game is a lot more -
it's definitely more diverse and their
ability to expose defenses when they
play man-to-man they have a great more
inventory of exposing that as well and
that's where the Rams will have to be
careful there was moments where the Rams
did okay against certain little pick
plays and things like that but at the
end of the day know if if Peyton gets a
feel for are you playing too much man
he's gonna dial up some the right plays
and screw your defense over but the Rams
don't do that anymore that's the good
thing the Rams
just dabble and man just here in there
it's that's really all they do and I'll
be interested to see what they do with
them Michael Thomas on the first third
down
ya know like last week how I said with
the Cowboys game you know the first four
third first few third downs they did
some different stuff and then they kind
of went back to what they do but it made
the Cowboys think like oh wait we can't
go to some of our bread and butters here
we're gonna have to think outside the
box and and that's always good to throw
in to a guy like Sean Payton's mind
early on to go oh okay I have to maybe
readjust how I think about those
situations do you think what I've
noticed also is Sean McVeigh is come out
after all these games they find one guy
to pick on during most of the game yeah
for the Eagles it was Sidney Jones and
I've seen a lot of other stories where
they're like we were gonna attack him
right do you think they're going to
focus
Peters they is that the matchup that you
focus on I don't necessarily think that
but again I know it's if you like to get
Peters you need time it's going to be
hard just because there's not gonna be
that matchup there you know the the Rams
have kind of said like for the most part
they're gonna go you know when I hear em
playing zone against Brees yeah doesn't
sound smart yeah but when you have a
great front for an incredible team speed
zone is a little different it's like you
know Jacksonville last year or whatever
Rams have the pieces to be the breeze
wrecker yes they do they definitely do
and if you think about back about last
week too even with the Cowboys like you
know there was the slant by Cooper for
the touchdown right where they kind of
caught the Rams and a good coverage yeah
but then after that you know the other
touchdown was set up by a play that was
completely smothered and covered and
they got pressure on Prescott and then
he scrambled to the left and threw a
great ball down the left sideline that
got them down to the one-inch line or
just and that was you know a great
physical play by a quarterback I don't
look at that and go oh man the Rams are
blue that or that's an issue there so to
me the Rams have put together three or
four weeks now in a row of me going man
they got it on defense they know what
they want to do they're not being overly
complicated they have like one wrinkle
wink a week and back then in week 9 it
was like you know we're gonna annihilate
this play right here when they get in
this formation
oh gosh damn we didn't think they would
do that in that formation oh [ __ ] we're
screwed
there's a 30 yard game what I love about
both teams in this game is that if
either goes down early right they're
confident to get back definitely
the Rams have been in this situation
against this exact team in week nine
right aints were in this situation
against the Eagles last week yes I don't
think I have anything else
I don't either let's go to the next one
alright guys so just a recap real quick
you are both picking the Rams to win you
are both taking the Rams plus three and
a half for 800 bleacher bucks each
championship game 640 on Sunday the New
England Patriots on the road visiting
the Kansas City Chiefs these two teams
played earlier in the year Sunday Night
Football week six Patriots won at 43 to
for tea at home in New England let's
talk about the weather it does not look
like the Arctic freeze is going to
happen I've been doing a lot of research
on the weather yeah it's called climate
change
yeah and global warming yeah I mean
there's the Arctic it's still gonna be
that away I'm still gonna be cold you're
not gonna be in the negative right as of
now AccuWeather is projecting 22 degrees
during warmup okay 20 degrees during the
first quarter right and then 19 degrees
from the second quarter okay factor in
that change first a second quarter one
degree I'm moon update coming as well as
that where you're going no okay I want
to explain to people something that I
saw online from John Ewing in the Action
Network that will impact the way that
you bet on football games in the cold
for the rest of your life because I was
confused by it for Chiefs Colts and I
what got me confused was when your boy
Tony Dungy said I've played in a lot of
cold weather games I more points are
scored in cold-weather games it's
natural to see snow or to see
20-something degrees and assume it's
colder less points yeah they went and
looked offense knows where they're going
but this is the main thing let me break
it down like this there are three types
of Colt there's 20 to 30 degree cold
right there's 10 to 20 and there's 0 to
10 and they should not be treated equal
they're not so when there are games that
are lower than 30 degrees the over is
actually hitting fifty eight point eight
percent of the time when the weather is
under 30 degrees okay
the over is hitting almost 60 percent of
the time which means Vegas is making
lower point totals because they're
expecting people to bet the under and
it's mainly going over when it gets
interesting is when it's under 10 I
believe everyone thinks about cold as
though it's under 10 when it's under 10
the under has gone regular season and
playoffs 16 6 and 1 almost 80% of the
time what they found is that if they're
super snow or they're super cold under
10 and that's when it's a super low
scoring game but we think that when it's
25 25 doesn't impact it at all means
nothing but when it's the suit
Pirlo or you get two feet of snow that's
when it impacts it's the same thing when
you lose a player on a team versus when
you lose a quarterback if you lose todd
gurley it's gonna have a big impact but
if you lose Jared Goff that's the super
impact because the positional importance
that's just my thing for for the rest of
your life when you're seeing flurries
and your rush to pound the under don't
because Vegas might bring it down and
that's when you should actually bet the
over only when it's frigid under ten
there's only been one NFL playoff game
under ten degrees and the New England
Patriots played in it 2004 against the
Titans
really so doesn't Green Bay Giants
wasn't under ten a few years ago Gordon
a pro Football Reference it wasn't
that's also wrong the freezer ball was
gonna check it out bangles bangles
chargers - pharmacist I'm just telling
you it's wrong I know I didn't know that
all right yeah well this game in NFL
history is I just think that's it was
important information absolutely I was
sitting there on Saturday going I don't
know how this colds gonna impact the
game ya know it does but I just didn't
know how yeah on the Blood Moon and I'll
give you the spread clouds are in the
forecast so we might not see the Blood
Moon until the fourth quarter just want
to make sure everyone is aware of that
spread in this game Kansas City - three
Chris yeah break it down yeah and to
your point with the cold they elect that
no player cares when it's 25 that's not
even like that's not gonna make anybody
about an eye unless maybe you're from
Miami or Tampa or something like that
Joey Bosa was miked up for the Patriots
games he's like I can't feel my arm oh
yes see that's your you've lost already
and that's that's but but ten degrees is
a different game because now 10 degrees
when you're below 10 and I really only I
don't think I ever played him below 10
other than in high school I mean I
played in Nebraska where it was like in
the teens and New England in the mid 20s
once but when you get to 10 the field
can also become frozen the ball becomes
so hard and so slick and when you're
down in like 8 9 degrees you you really
have a hard time keeping your body loose
and warm on the sidelines when I was
crong yeah there's been 26 games I was
gonna say so under 10 degrees right
so let me tell you into a really attic
that's actually interesting yeah
Oakland let me get him by order Oakland
Cleveland
so Seattle at Minnesota was the last one
right the playoffs that was ten nine
yeah
Minnesota already said that Dallas
Detroit that was indoors it doesn't
count Green Bay San Francisco that was a
wild card game a few years ago yes that
was five degrees right 49ers one twenty
two twenty three twenty three to twenty
s Rodgers broken collar and then your
Green Bay din New York Giants right you
said that was negative one right that
was twenty three to twenty right and
then New England Tennessee was seventeen
fourteen yeah Green Bay Carolina was 32
thirteen but oh yeah the championship
game where Brett Favre won his first
championship against Kerry Collins these
are like three and negative seven and
yeah yeah that's why I thought cuz I
just knew like the the old Dan Fouts
verse the Bengals game was the the
freezer ball where it was like one of
the coolest games ever that's where I
was like I yet I'm so getting back to
three down all right Joshy um all right
first thing is going back to the first
game gosh I just didn't remember this
but like they didn't match up the New
England Patriots in the first game like
they didn't match up which I think just
speaks volumes because it just tells you
that they were scared a little bit from
that aspect they they a team like the
New England Patriots who wanna play
man-to-man more than any team in
football at no point did they really say
Oh Gilmore you got tyree kill if they
played man they just played who ever
came to their side but for the most part
New England took the approach of let's
play soft coverage and not give up big
plays and make them work the ball down
the field now one of the things they did
during the game they did try to disrupt
Kelsey a lot which is what New England
always does like they'll disrupt the
number one guy right they'll take the
defensive end and Kelsey could be split
out five yards from the from the rest of
the the line like the tackle and the
defensive end will go out with him like
a Dante Hightower Jam him and then rush
and so those are the things that they
did um I think that the one other thing
I took away
from that game I do think the the Chiefs
the Chiefs can put New England and a
bind of course because the Chiefs have a
very good off it's a line they can run
the football and now they're hitting the
diamond there are getting the doctor
back and if that's again if Andy Reed
can stay patient with the run and stay
with that that'll be a huge factor in
the game I really thought I was going to
go into this saying like I wouldn't mind
seeing the Chiefs get underneath the
center and getting some power sets and
running the football but I think what I
took away from the first matchup is
don't do that you're not going to out
size out size New England if you want to
run the ball spread them out and run it
because they are scared of the speed and
what mahomes and Watkins and all they've
been doing the past game so therefore
when you were in the shotgun and the
spread formations a lot of to safety
looks or cover three soft zone looks to
where it could favor the run game as far
as that is concerned now the Pats were
definitely conscious of not letting
Patrick mahomes go right in the pocket
and that will certainly be another
element in this game he threw the
interception in the end zone Hightower
was on his back now he did escape right
like we talked about earlier in the
podcast early in the week where he threw
the long touchdown pass damn Kareem hunt
but he escaped and like went back in the
pocket like nine yards and just because
he's Patrick mahomes
he's still capable throwing 50 yard
lasers so that's the Patrick of a home's
effect right if he really is he's
beautiful
mahomes was about as off in the start of
that game as you ever seen my homes he
missed about three or four slam dunk big
plays
Kareem hunt down the seam for a
touchdown Tyree killa on a deep cross
that should have been a touchdown so he
was off and certainly a little fostered
in that game the Pats secondary it's
much better now that's the other thing I
would say that's a big thing because JC
Jackson was not even a part of that
conversation that week that was still
Eric Rowe trying to match up and play
man-to-man and they have found the right
formula of mixing and matching with JC
Jackson and Gilmour that is a special
duo and then McCourty in the mix as well
and then the other McCourty at safety
and his ability to play man or just be
the deep center fielder and his
that's gonna make things a little
different for for the Chiefs passing
game in general I think that's about all
I had from that side of the matchup the
first time around yeah and like I said
the Pats tried to play soft coverages
keep everything in front of them the
problem with that that I'll posed
everybody is when you play soft
coverages in zone like we've seen and
your pass rush can't contain mahomes
like the other long touchdown pass a
Tyree kill right there playing a deep
cover three another one where he jumped
up and stopped and then outran the guy
was like amazing the the most forgotten
best play of the season right that was
amazing but that that's the fear of the
zone because now you have a zone and
everybody's gone the safeties going oh
my gosh she's gonna run a deep bomb and
okay then my home's buys a little time
and he just goes well I throw a laser
right in between you know the second
level dropping linebackers and the
safety and now we'll complete it that
way so that's where you know it can be
dangerous to play soft zones against
Patrick mahomes at times because we've
talked about his ability to move and
then manipulate coverage and make big
plays that way um so I don't think New
England can depend a whole lot on
mahomes missing some of the throws he
missed and also that was probably the
first time he was really challenged as a
quarterback in his NFL career to go I
haven't seen these defenses or nobody
did this to me before and you know with
like Dante how her acting like he's in a
blitz and then dropping back to get the
interception or Dante Hightower at the
line of scrimmage and as soon as mahomes
breaks right he's breaking with him to
either cut him off or at least make it
hard for him to throw or hit him as he's
throwing it now the other thing on the
other side of the ball um you know Brady
had a stupid fumble right remember where
he tried to buy time and like try to be
Patrick mahomes and then like they were
kind of being controlled the game and he
fumbled the football also I think the
other thing that we got to remember too
is the Patriots it kind of got control
of the game and they let up a big kick
return that the Chiefs got the ball down
all the way to the three yard line to
get a quick touchdown just little things
I'm saying like I wouldn't depend on
those type of things happening again
yeah I
expect from the homes to miss the throws
he missed I don't expect Brady to dance
around and think he's mahomes and fumble
or the the Patriots special teams
they'll end up a 97 New York tick return
like those are things that they were
cool they affected the game but I just
think playoff football will be different
and you won't see those type of things
if they do happen then whoever makes
those mistakes is going to lose the
football game now uh-oh
damn okay alright and the last thing
sorry sorry just I just wanna made this
apologize with the Chiefs offense and
the Patriots defense me the Patriots did
a good job but just on some sneaky every
now and then like oh it's third and
seven and they would all out blitz yes
right and I don't think the Chiefs were
ever thinking like Oh Dan they'll allow
up blitz us and leave no safety in the
middle fina caught them by surprise
yeah the back flow yes right he just
didn't they didn't have a plan on what
to do so I would expect them to have a
plan for that this time and really I
would expect New England to think they
have a plan and actually never do that
and probably drop out every time they
give the look if I was New England
that's or my Zen master New England time
that's what I would expect them to do
now to flip it over the others way with
New England on just that first Matt no
Josh Gordon right that's a big thing
then caught the winning touchdown there
the throw up he didn't catch the winning
such and Gronk caught that seemed to
fade to put them and feel a little
position to end the game to make it
Borden have the touchdown before that
right he did I think he I don't think he
had a touchdown he got a pass
interference call down at the one-yard
line that's an aspect for New England
that hurts do England because you know
the chief secondary is a little bit
better now and now you don't have to
worry about Gordon Gordon was a matchup
problem for them and the and when Brady
saw man he was just not afraid to throw
the ball up to Gordon or if it was
man-to-man and he had a slant
he was like I'm just gonna jam in the
amount they play his own writing man um
the Pats in the first game came out
trying to spread the field at first and
slowly got back to let's get I formation
let's run the ball let's do all of that
one thing I saw from the first game they
got to be careful about pulling the
guard over Chris Jones because just like
we talked with an errand Donald or
Fletcher cus you pulled the guard in
front of them he will pull with you and
stop it so that was a good thing but the
Pats did do a good job I thought
uh being unpredictable in this way they
stayed with the run but they stayed with
the run even in the spread right left go
where yeah we got in the I form and then
the next series they came out and oh
it's 11 personnel we got three receivers
and Gronk on the field and it looks like
we're gonna throw it and they still
stayed with the run and they ran
play-action out of the shotgun like just
you know riding like the read they're
RPO type of look but they don't do our
POS but it's just like a true
play-action pass so I thought that was
very impressive by them other things do
you have to take an advantage in that
and that matchup um the Orlando
Scandrick was playing Justin Houston
really was not just in Houston at that
point he was still battling he liked his
little knee issues right to where that's
advantaged Kansas City and I certainly
think he can be a difference maker I
mean it's really interesting first of
all just for everybody out there the
Chiefs almost had three people and
double-digit sacks
I mean Ford and Chris Jones got double
digits and Justin Houston was at nine
sacks I mean I I'm truly trying to think
Justin off the top of my head football
you guys know me I've been paying
attention forever I can't think of a
team that had three double-digit sack
players I don't know if that's possible
to look up but I mean I know they didn't
get the double digits but it's still
very close it just shows you their
ability to pass rush with the fourth
house Eric Berry been playing well I
mean he's really he didn't do anything
last week you know he's he played spotty
up to that and he's still having a heal
this year so I don't think they can
depend on him and it doesn't sound like
that is going to be in the fold for him
let me just make sure I got everything
okay um then I think the Chiefs played a
little too much man-to-man and the first
matchup I do because once the Patriots
got to feel like oh man they're gonna
play man-to-man like this all the time
that's where you saw Gronk catch the
seam down the sideline or a throw up
ball to Josh Gordon or some pick plays
that they got on the Kansas City Chiefs
I mean nobody has more pick plays than
the New England Patriots so you have to
be careful and I think they did that a
little too much they got to be careful
about when they do it you know they're
playing man-to-man a Brady fakes the
wide receiver screen and then the seam
guy goes up the slot for you know or the
slot guy goes up
seem for like 20 yard game because
they're thinking they're gonna throw the
screen um but yeah at the end of the day
you know I think this is a different
Chiefs defense I think they have found
more of a talented secondary on the
field from the first time around okay
but I would also say like we said
already vice versa
the Patriots secondary is much more
talented this time around I also look at
the Chiefs D line with ajust in Houston
certainly more dangerous um I'm just
trying to make sure I got all my points
out here just said I don't want to leave
anything and I'm sure they'll pop up to
me as you start to talk or whatever else
but I think at the end of the day it
came down to one thing to me um I'm
rooting for Andy Reid okay I want and I
am like I'm rooting for the Chiefs I
don't want it I don't not trying to hide
it or anything I am rooting for the
Chiefs on Sunday and I really want to
see Andy Reid win a Super Bowl
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna be root for
Andy Reid all the way through if he does
it I don't think there's a matchup on
the other side but but my brain my brain
says eight hundred dollars on the New
England Patriots I think the Patriots
are gonna win the football game and
really when it comes down to it at the
end of the day it's not the Andy Reid
part I'm scared of it's the Bob Sutton
verse Belichick McDaniels that I'm
scared of and I think New England with
the run game
the way it's rolling right now I just
think is gonna put them in a tremendous
bind I expect this game to be really
close I certainly would not be shocked
if the Kansas City Chiefs won but I
think when I really look at it in the
way the Patriots are playing on the
defensive side of the ball
having seen mahomes and Tyreke kill and
I really just look at it and I said this
to you earlier Josh where I really think
the Chiefs can win but it's going to
take a handful of just out of this
[ __ ] world type plays by Patrick
mahomes where and he's capable of doing
that so that certainly scares me so
that's why I go to the Patriots and I
really see it as a similar type of score
as the other game 28 24 27 24 that type
of game where the Patriots I think
you're gonna pull it off and I be
playing the Los Angeles Rams in the
Super Bowl what's your official score
prediction I'm saying I'm gonna say mmm
I'm gonna go what was I officially pick
the other one I've planned as Hannah
said the same thing because I kind of
feel like they're in the same boat yeah
I don't remember what she said for the
other one I really think both games are
gonna be like 27 24 28 24 right there in
the mid-twenties all right so if you
enough you want me to nail one down and
just a number that's okay but yeah yeah
that'll work settle words so okay sorry
okay so let me give you some history
yeah
I've said this before Bill Belichick has
coached 342 games in his career it's
astounding that in those 342 he's only
lit up 40 points seven times amazing is
that and three of them are from Andy
Reid and they've happened recently 2018
2017 2014 forty this past season the
season we just had 42 the season opener
in 2017 and 41 in 2014 the last time the
Tom Brady played in Kansas City right
that was the first it's all crashing
down yeah maybe it's time to play Jimmy
Garoppolo game yeah it's pretty wild
that this is the first time that Tom
Brady has been back since that game yeah
Bill Belichick versus Andy Reid is 6 and
2 he is two and OH in the playoffs Tom
Brady in Kansas City is one in two for
his career he's lost the last two he's
thrown for about 241 yards in those
three games his touchdown to
interception ratio is 3 to 6 and the
last two in Kansas City the Patriots
have scored 14 points and 16 points and
it was not this cold yeah also
Patriots are three and five on the road
this season
those three wins were at the Jets at the
bills where Tom Brady played awful and
at the Bears where they led up
30-something points in a wild up and
back game with some miracle picks by the
Patriots this season the Patriots have
lost three of their last four road games
in 2014 before they lost to Denver in
the championship game they lost three of
their last four road games they were 7 &
1 at home that year they were 5 & 3 on
the road in 2012 when they lost the
other time to Denver in the championship
game they lost four of their last six
Road games they were eight now at home
that year they were four and four on the
road Patriots are eight know at home
this year there's three and five on the
road and they've lost three of their
last four road games I just found this
on reddit the Patriots in rematches from
the regular season this is up until 2014
I don't have 15 16 17 18 they're 9 and 8
just let it's a rematch that's
interesting but all of the Patriots 8
postseason losses up to that point were
rematches hmm you would think it would
benefit Belichick right the other big
stat that I thought was very interesting
and this is a little bit more arbitrary
but I still think it's interesting
because of what you said about Bob
Sutton in their last 34 games including
the postseason the Chiefs have not
allowed an opponent to score 30 points
or more at home right the longest such
streak since the Jaguars went 41
straight home games from oh three two oh
eight and that's from rich rhobar I look
at this game and it's another one where
I'm going I'm taking Andy Reed who I
know has a tendency to abandon the run
with a quarterback that has never been
in this position before but I don't
think that impacts Patrick mom
I don't either I don't want to play that
game nope
it is Brady it is Belichick and I know
that the New England team that lost to
Denver Denver and Indy is not the same
team as this team but I also this is the
reason why I put it was confident in the
Patriots last week they're a different
team at home than they are on the road I
went back and I watched that Patriots
Denver 2015 game that offense was
struggling the only reason they got half
their points was because Peyton Manning
threw a pass that was ruled behind the
line of scrimmage and they get the ball
inside the 20 other than that it was one
drive to end of the game to get another
touch - how many times did he throw the
ball in that game do you remember I told
shake it oh my gosh
I like 14 or some nonsense no I was
talking about Brady oh yeah because they
didn't run that year that was their
problem they couldn't run the thing that
scares me the most if your vote picking
the Chiefs is it feels as though this
team of the Patriots 56 times Brady did
it they were so well I was talking about
Payton Oh for like the 14 yeah the thing
that if you're going with the Chiefs
scares me is it does feel like this
Patriots team is built to beat this
Chiefs team yeah they have the secondary
guys that can match up because they're
so good at an island even though no one
really matches up with Tyreke I could
see them putting Gilmore on Kelsey and
eliminating him or and or JC Jackson
because JC Jackson's great with size yes
Vick and then from the offensive
perspective they can do the 12 play 5
minute drive with the running game they
can do what we thought the Colts could
do and keep Patrick mahomes off the
field yep I will do what you're rooting
for and I am putting $800 on the Chiefs
- 3 I believe I wanted to because I
wanted me not to do it yeah - block you
from beating me no I'm just kidding I'm
gonna do the Chiefs yeah I I feel dumb
betting against the page I don't think
you should feel dumb it's mom I don't
think there's a bad choice here but if
the Patriots win we're gonna be sitting
there going though you brothers the
Patriots of the championship game you
know I mean like that's what I'm gonna
say to myself I know but don't day
that's just like I think the Patriots
are built to beat the Chiefs yeah
the Chiefs have the perfect team to
Patriot you know how do you beat the
Patriots a front for that can get
pressure exactly and then drop back with
a quarterback that you can't game plan
for right that other Chiefs I know with
a wide receiver that doesn't matter if
you put two or three on them like I felt
like the Patriots were double and
tripping teaming him last time and
Patrick mahomes missed another easy
touchdown to him like ona on an out with
one of those routes I don't even know
how it's described it came from the
right to the left all the way he went
left and then inside and went back out
left and Patrick yeah I know he had him
there too I know there was a number of
plays I think that the last time they
played everything went the Patriots way
right the great plays were just Patrick
mahomes making great plays but the
turnovers and the ball control and who
had the ball at the end of the game and
where the game was no I'm just the the
trend that shocking is the Patriots on
the road in the playoffs yeah they're
not that reliable the one I found the
most interesting there was you there
repeat matchups that was a good one cuz
you just think that Belichick the second
time around yes have you down even
better but according to this 23rd the
2013 AFC championship game
yeah the 2012 AFC championship game
Ravens
it says Ravens Superbowl yeah 2012 the
Ravens but the Super Bowl and played the
the 49ers and beaten right-right-right
2011 they played in the AFC Championship
game in the Patriots one remember where
the Ravens receiver dropped the ball in
the end zone yeah and this wild card
right Ravens have done it a few times
where they've had a rematch and the
Ravens actually won sure it's it's
fascinating because I guess you know you
could probably I just don't think you
can game plan to stop Patrick mahomes no
you cannot I'll just boil it down to one
thing I think that's really gonna
dictate the game right off the bat right
off the bat like if the Chiefs jump out
early
the game's over they're gonna win I'm
just telling you they're going to win
because the crowd know it in the pass
rush will then
to Kansas City's favor so everybody out
there and Bella checked referenced this
early in the week about how they start
fast and I know that's what they're
gonna be obsessed with this week in New
England because he's obsessed with like
we always talk about taking away your
best option well one of the best things
Kansas City does is start fast and hits
all he's gonna beat into their team's
brains this week when you say that
they're obsessed with something in New
England it's a situation where they're
gonna go we have to win the first five
minutes of the game and how does that
get communicated to the player I mean
he's gonna say that probably in a team
meeting on Monday morning he said to me
like the first thing he says to them
about we have to win this situation and
whatever else and he's going to go into
some things that he thinks they need to
take away from that you know so that is
a huge thing and if it gets to that one
of my big worries is Brady has shown
signs of being jumpy in the pocket so if
they get down and it's 17-7 chiefs or
14-3 chiefs and all of a sudden
gosh New England can't rely on the run
game in Kansas City goes hey do your
play-action passes we're not gonna react
too hard and we're gonna play pass in
those sets then it's gonna be tee off
time let's start to get the pass rush
there and that's where we could see a
Brady struggle in Kansas City I just
want to say one thing - we're talking
about how both of these are coin flips
yeah one of them on Monday is most
likely not gonna look like that when you
look at the last five years and
championship games in general
last year Patriots win by four Eagles
win by 31 I thought that was gonna be
close yeah the year before that Falcons
win by 23 Patriots win by 19 the year by
so just sorry I don't mean who the
Patriots play in that one was that the
Patriots so the Steelers oh the Steelers
gosh but that was you know that's I'm
just going yeah I know Broncos beat the
Patriots by two the year before Panthers
won by 34 over the Cardinals in what we
thought was gonna be a coin flip game
with carson palmer and that offense
being great year before that Seahawks
win by six yeah
Patriots win by 38 over the Colts the
year before that Broncos win by 10
Seahawks win by six I think of the the
Giants beating the Vikings Vikings by 42
back in 2000 like yeah
there are some championship games sure
most years where one team beats the crap
out of the other take it down and the
other team panics and they start to do
things that they wouldn't normally do
I hope that so--that's will be my
follow-up question to you of the two
games which matchup could produce a
blowout in which side oh what's the most
likely to produce a blowout
I just rise those are all home blow up
yeah so but I'd so I want to throw just
like so it just sends to me that you
think the Chiefs could blow up the
Patriots I guess I mean I don't really
think so I want to throw holes in all
those theories that please know I love
it like the Falcons Packers game come on
Packers weren't even in the same
stratosphere was number 12 making magic
to get them there and then they had to
play a team that was so overwhelming to
them okay right so that would be what I
argue that go through some of the other
ones it was like Steelers Patriots
Patriots was Kansas City they had to
delay the game until Sunday night member
and the that was the Antonio Brown
Facebook they had less time to prepare
for the football game and had a deal
with all that Panthers beat the
Cardinals play that was just a straight
ass whuppin now there's nothing I can
even say to throw a rager you should
beat the Colts by 38 that was when the
Colts shouldn't haven't even been there
they had they beat the Denver in Denver
where Denver was clearly the better team
but hey the Colts had a good game plan
that week and Andrew Luck made some big
plays and we were starting to see the
end of noodle arm Manning where he
couldn't make any throws there but yes
that was a matchup that favored of
course the new engine sound like if the
Chiefs get out to an early lead
it's the perfect generation it could be
scary yeah I guess if Jared Goff is kind
of playing a little poopy pants sure the
Saints could just kind of explode
no because the Saints are one of those
teams when I got scared about that pick
yeah where if they were running out of
the middle of Ingram and getting the
toss with chimera and the slant with
with Michael Thomas you're you're just
getting cut death I know I this is for
my own self scouting but the the Rams
and the Chiefs are both athletically
superior I feel like to their matchups
yeah I think there's a lot of yes
superiority there in a lot of ways the
Chiefs second I mean the the Patriots on
defense and their secondaries is
athletic as it's been but you
I I'm really interested just from my own
self because like again I think when I
was not in the weeds earlier this week
okay and I haven't had any daddy cigars
all week I'm talking about truly in the
weeds of just football X's and O's and
things like a single one not a single
one thank you for clarifying yes good
from daddy cigars will be a flowing
though Friday night but oh maybe we'll
hang out then but but the the thing is
yes my original just intuition said it's
going to be Chiefs Saints and going back
watching the games and more importantly
really just watching last weekend's
games started to sway me
so you flipped on both game I flipped on
both games I Monday morning of you and I
think I set it on the on the podcast on
Monday I said I'm leaning I'm leaning
Saints Chiefs when we had to what ok so
I have to follow up yeah what I'm gonna
ask you afterwards was what did you see
in the film that meant swayed you right
but my question right now is who did you
pick when we started the playoffs that
you thought was gonna gonna go to the
Super Bowl
Saints Chiefs no I said Saints Patriots
yeah I thought saying some said Saints
Jess so what was the big thing from the
film of watching both games um I just
think at the end I like I kind of said
with the Rams game I think the Rams when
I know mainly Chiefs Patriots oh just
after watching both games I think that
the the Patriots secondary their way
they're playing and this combination of
hey the way Brady threw the ball last
week and made me think maybe there was
an issue with his knee okay to a degree
and the way they are running the
football they have just found I think
the right formula on the offensive side
of the ball so well yeah there's
matchups that I like with Kansas City
but you know some of it can get muted
again like we saw last week with Bosa
and Ingram if this formula continues to
work and I just don't know if there's
all ticket well there's not a more
complex running game in all of football
than the New England Patriots I just
think that when I look at the Patriots
offensive line it's the Chris Jones's
and the Fletcher Cox sure that mess with
Brady not the edge guys they figure that
out I don't even know if it was Von
Miller in those games
as much as it was the Malik Jackson's
and some of the other guys in the
interior I just think that the ED the
problem with this year's Patriots team
they're better in the interior ARSA that
I'm just you know I feel like I've
watched Patriots and critical games
where David Andrews gets pushed around a
little not this year no no it's been
Trent Brown and Marcus kin and that's
where I'm saying if they get up to that
lead they will not be able to block D
Ford in Houston off the edge that's
where I would say oh when you combine
those two guys with the pressure in the
middle of Chris Jones yes
I'm wondering does James White have to
stay in and help block a little bit more
just because I find those guys more
threatening than the Chargers guys that
they are I mean there's no doubt about
that there's no doubt they are they are
more threatening they also I also
thought the Chargers came into the
Patriots a little bit beaten down from
playing the Ravens sure we're like the
the the Chiefs are kind of like we kind
of got to rest a little bit they did
they certainly didn't have to put the
pedal of the metal all game long so
which one are you more confident in I'm
not really confident I'm not either
that's what I would say about 800 I
think got more common in the Rams game I
am I think I'm more common in the Rams
game yeah but again I would not be
shocked as either you could take the
lead recapping the Betts Saints Rams
spread in that game New Orleans - three
and a half you guys are both taking the
Rams and the points for 800 and then
Patriots at the Chiefs spread is Chiefs
- three Sims you are taking New England
plus three for 800 left go has taken
Kansas City - three for 800 before we
wrap up what Super Bowl are both of you
rooting for what do you want to see on
Monday mmm well I think I'm rooting for
the one that I picked with your bats I'm
rooting for and not just because my best
Rams Chiefs like I said this week this
year has been defined by high point
totals and exciting games and we are
seeing two of the four best games like
football Outsiders did by the DVO a the
best play games of the year and two of
them were are being played a rematch
this weekend and the Rams Chiefs was
three of the four yeah so the fact that
we could have this this collision
those great games again to see Sean
McVeigh which I think has been the story
of the season and the off season yeah
with all these coaches being hired
against Patrick mahomes which i think is
really the story of the season that to
me is the best culmination personally I
am NOT interested in hearing a breeze
and Brady two-week waxing poetic about
their careers I don't want to hear about
all of the totals and all that stuff and
it's not just because they beat the
Eagles it's because I want to see
Patrick mahomes in the Super Bowl and I
want to see Tyree kill on a fast track
and I want to see two weeks of of all
this stuff and I Travis Kelce I consider
a friend of mine and I'd like to see him
on that stage and from the Rams
perspective like this was a team that
when they got in da Mike and Sue and
they traded for Marcus Peters that's
another story line Marcus Peters against
the team that traded him in the Super
Bowl I think that's exciting and I am
just over Brady and Brees it's just they
were they were great and they're still
great but I'm ready for this a season
about offensive explosion to end with a
rematch of the best offensive explosion
game who do you want to say that's the
game I least want to say oh I don't want
to see that at all how come cuz I just
don't like those games it's just not fun
to me there's no pressure it's just like
oh you score don't worry we'll draw this
in the dirt and we're gonna go down and
score it it's just there's no man you
know like the Super Bowl last year I did
but I think it was a little I mean I get
scared of 54-51 but I was 41 30 or 40
133 whatever bag is scared of 54:51 I
don't like that necessarily that game I
I don't know I just I am I'm rooting for
Chiefs Saints okay which is another
great story that's what I would love to
see but I would also love to see
Patriots Saints I mean I really would or
Patriots Rams I mean Patriots saints or
I I know it's so annoying to hear that
story but those quarterbacks they're
gonna be like oh my gosh it's my legacy
against Brees and Sean Payton and will
not be afraid of Belichick oh he will
not and I think you know again anything
with New England in the Super Bowl is
going to you know ignite the hate factor
right it heightens the perceived
importance exactly so because then you
start talking about Bill Walsh you start
talking about Chuck Noll and you start
talking about like if Brady wins six
yeah all those I mean listen Chiefs Rams
if that happen i like like left go just
said there's no match up that's really
bad i guess that would be my least one
but i am rooting for chief Saints and
I'm picking the other teams this is
really hard for me because I had to sit
back and go like alright Hart leave Hart
leave yeah I will say this that when I
look at the I think Saints Chiefs like
from our podcast perspective Saints
Chiefs is the best one for this show
yeah because we've spent so much time
talk about mahomes versus Brees and as I
said before the fact that the MVP comes
out the night before that whole
weekend's gonna feel like a big
discussion right Rams Patriots is the
rematch of the tooth is is the rematch
of the Super Bowl that launched the
Patriots dynasty yeah and and it's the
new greatest show on turf right that's
great too and Saints Patriots this man
you're right yeah yeah it's just it's
two great coaches it's quarterbacks that
I do think are very aware of their
legacy and they want to beat each other
yeah I'll never forget being at the
Super Bowl last year and how hard it was
for Vikings fans to have Eagles fans in
their city ever having just lost to them
alright it caused it actually caused a
lot of drama with my family I've told
you that story I think where we're
sitting in a restaurant and this
waitress goes over to a table of
Patriots fans right next to us and goes
so happy to have a table of Patriots
fans
I hate Eagles fans and my mom goes my
mom goes are you [ __ ] kidding me and
my mom's not like that right cuz we were
right there and it was really weird
because Vikings fans for I'm hoping
again for Falcons like there was looked
as if it's Saints Patriots the host city
is gonna be miserable well what the
results of the stories of like Eagles
fans mistreating Vikings fans at the
Eagles game right so that in Nigel and
then I told you what happened and you
you you were cool with it when the
Vikings fans when hundreds of them went
to the rocky statue and put the Vikings
jersey on rocky and the skull chant on
the steps and then said why are you
treating us bad remember that and then
you went oh no I get it now all right I
just I think that it's also like a
popular narrative but I'm just saying
for the host city to have the team that
came back from down 28 to 3 and their
bitter rival and one of them's winning
yeah that would be killer the only thing
I'll say who would they hate more
singing my only thing will be this if it
is Patriots Saints and the Patriots come
back from down like 28 to 3 on the
Saints yeah and they do it to them
Oh would that be beautiful huh just from
that perspective Oh starting the music
Gary running us off yeah no no no you
turn this music off I will finish my
speech easily the most
[Applause]
oh do believe math lab gumbo time in New
Orleans I was just say the funniest most
Awkward part of award shows is what that
happens hold on
who are you picking who am i picking I
kind of want to see Rams Chiefs you guys
do that - yeah so you're like that I
like the scoring yeah I hear you
actually no I want chief Saints because
I want it to be mahomes Brees because
I'm thinking about the content right and
I want a full week two weeks of us being
able to break that talk so much about
that and honestly so many things have
happened this year that have aligned
with Sims in Lufkin right from contracts
and coaches it would be a good memory to
the season right yeah good end yeah for
Sims sound homey forfend rec good
evening everybody
and I am the lef koe man we will holla
holla holla at you later good luck with
your tickets we'll talk to you soon
[Music]